I watched somebody berate someone the
other day at the airport for cutting
them in line
can you understand
whole Auditorium right now and I ask
people what their
come 99 of it is dumb ass [__] We
complain about the dumbest [__] and then
real [__] happens and we're like oh [__]
like I have some friends and relatives
that complain so much that it gets me to
such a crazy level I said to one
relative I'm like man I wish something
really bad happened to you I don't mean
it but what I was trying to say to them
is you complain about nonsense Karen at
work is ruining me what's the matter
I'll tell you what's the matter people
are unhappy
it matters we have to fight for our own
happiness over everything over
everything I don't meditate it's not
exercise I don't [__] Watch Rocky 4
videos I wake up and I say my God
another [__] day on this Earth where
the people I love are good I'm good now
let me go work for 15 hours and have 800
[__] things go wrong